I've had to give up on other things just
to be able to get gas to and from work
once a week the struggle is real real at
the gas pump that is gas prices soaring
as drivers notice daily increases it's
actually 589 up the street six dollars
plus on a strip this car cost sixty
dollars to fill up and this was a 35-40
car to fill up and here in North Las
Vegas some of the lowest prices we've
seen for gas with it being 4.99 a gallon
for regular here on Cheyenne Avenue I
have to fill up at least once a week
with my commute to work so and this is
the place where I stop because it's been
the cheapest that I've found around the
valley but as other parts of the country
see gas prices fall they remain at an
all-time high here on the West Coast and
seem to still be going up spokesperson
with the western state petroleum
Association says that unfortunately
people are feeling the effects right now
of California policies on their
pocketbooks Nevada primarily is getting
their petroleum Diesel from Utah and but
also in Las Vegas mostly from La based
refineries and in La it's an expensive
place to operate according to AAA the
national average for gas is right around
3.80 and Nevada's average five dollars
and 48 cents in North Las Vegas Madison
Kimbrough 8 news now and to put this all
in perspective just how much gasoline
increase we have seen according to AAA
this time last year we're at 389 cents a
gallon for regular gasoline 389.